Hi, this is Alex Coulomb, and now we're going to take everything Pete has shown in the previous
course sections and apply them to create replacement footage for our level sequence.
So to get started with the VCam application in Unreal, you're going to want to make sure
you have a few plugins on.
One will be your virtual cam.
One will be pixel streaming.
And the final one will be Live Link.
Once those are enabled and you've restarted, all you'll have to do is activate pixel streaming
in the dropdown here.
You can just say launch signaling server.
And once that's active, you're going to want to take note of your IPv4 address there, the
local one, because we'll put that into the app in a moment.
We can also go ahead and just grab in our VCam actor, which you can also find under the plus
virtual production and VCam actor right there.
And once you have this activated, you might just want to tilt it slightly toward the person
you plan on capturing, bring it up a little higher if you want to.
And then what we're going to do is go under the component for the VCam actor, the one
called VCam.
And under here, we're going to want to make sure this is enabled, which will activate this
nice little UI.
And then we can close place actors to give us a little more screen real estate and go
to window virtual production live link.
And we can see that right now I've got a yellow colored icon here telling me that the VCam
app is detected, but it's not actually active right now.
So over on my iPhone, what I'll now do is go over to pixel streaming and again see 192.168.1.6.
And I will match that over here on my iPhone.
Don't worry about the port.
And I'll just hit connect or go.
And if it doesn't connect, make sure under settings you go and change your connection
type to pixel streaming.
That's key.
And let's try one more time, connect.
And it says it wants to use our microphone and right away we can see it spring to life.
I'm going to press OK for our tracking here.
And we can see we're now matching up our viewport and what we see in editor.
We've got a green light over here.
I can click on the UI elements directly in my viewport or use my finger inside the browser.
And I can start to actually move around my space.
And I can even walk around physically to get exactly the view I want before hitting record
to actually create a take.
So to start here, I am just walking around just giving a sense of a one to one relationship
between my real space and the virtual one.
And up, looks like I just lost my connection there.
Worth demonstrating.
And if you disconnect like what just happened to me, just make sure you go back into your
live link subject settings and just reconnect.
And here I am just walking around again.
And I just tried hitting the record button to show you that you can actually activate
recording a take directly from the app.
Short one there.
We'll review that in a bit.
And just demonstrating some of the wheels we have here for changing ISO and a number of
other settings that will look familiar to anyone who's ever operated a camera before.
Also note that we can move the camera around just using our fingers.
What registers as our right thumb will be rotation just along the Z axis.
And if we manage to get our left hand into there, that starts to register as your movement
on the X and Y axis.
And here's what it looks like if you are too close to a wall in your real space, you just
have to back up a little to find the floor again.
Couple other things in here.
If we hit this, we'll actually lock our augmented reality camera if we wanted to focus more on
some other manual settings or if we found a static view we want to keep.
And here we are with that left and right navigation that's manual.
And we're going to fly mode right now.
So now we're also able to navigate on the Z axis.
And here we are just recording another take.
And then we just tap that record button again when we're all done.
And when you're all done recording, you can just go ahead and uncheck that enabled setting
on the virtual camera.
And if we'd like, we can even take a look at some of the recordings we just got.
With take recorder, we can say review the last recording and lock to that camera cut
view and we can see whatever we've done.
Let's take a look at a couple others over in cinematics takes today's date.
And we can also see the one we made over here.
And you get a nice natural handheld camera effect.
So we'll see if we can use this one to replace one of the shots in our finished film.
So to find that, I'll start by searching for anything called film because that's the name
of these final sequences.
And we'll see that there is one here in 205.03 that says V cam drop.
So I'll open up this one to actually put our V cam file inside.
And so let's just review what we have in here at the moment.
So we'll lock to the viewport and we see we've got our pan up.
And you know what, right there, that's probably a good spot for our little shaky cam shot
because feels a little bit strange to suddenly have the camera move like that.
So maybe we can cut in right there.
I was going to scroll through the rest and see if there's anywhere else.
We might want to use our little shaky cam shot, but I like it over here.
So I'm going to double click on here and we'll see that we have a subsequence with additional
shots.
So I like this first shot as is.
And the second one right before that camera moves, that's where I'm going to try to insert
my V cam footage.
Now the tricky thing is my V cam footage did not record the animation that we have for
our mannequin in here.
So in order to have that come in correctly, we are going to want to copy that mannequin
data.
So I'll just grab that whole mannequin object with its animation and do control seed.
And now I'm just going to insert my V cam shot, which as we might recall is the one that
we called scene underscore one underscore O two.
We could certainly give that a better name.
This is fine for now.
And we'll actually drop it into its own track entirely down here.
If we wanted to actually overwrite what we have up here, maybe we can just snap it like
that because then we can actually leave the existing shot here for the moment.
And this one will be on top of it.
So there's the shot.
But of course you see we do not have our mannequin there.
So if we want to get our mannequin in, the easiest thing to do will now be to open up
in here and to paste in our mannequin with control V.
But then we get a message saying the sequences read only.
So be sure to go to the upper right and unlock it and we'll try again.
And then you might find that there's no animation here because of where the time scale is.
We're starting in a different time code here, but that can easily be fixed by going up to
here and grabbing the actual animation from here from Manny animation track.
And we will paste it manually into here.
And just drag that back to the beginning.
Now because of the alignment we have over here right now, we will want to make sure that
we're matching that.
So we'll actually snap to the beginning and you'll see that now we are aligning.
So we've got the head coming up right there.
And you'll see that if I were to disable this, uncheck active, we see that the hand is an
exactly the same spot.
But maybe we like the beginning of what we had there.
So we could kind of cut and choose where we want to keep the old animation.
So maybe right before that camera starts to move, like right as the hand is coming up,
that's where we use it.
A little bit of confusion.
And then maybe we cut it off right before that shrug.
So right about here.
So one more time.
Original new shaky cam, confusion, and there's a shrug.
And then everything plays on as normal.
So at that point, if we wanted to, we could start to clip this more.
I could use my shortcut control forward slash and start to pull this apart.
Or just remind myself that this is continuous and leave that on top.
Depends how you want to do it.
But there's our easy insert of our V cam shot into the larger sequence.
That's it for the practical application.
And in the next section, Pete will review what we've done so far.